欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一小节我们来讲一下关于店铺诊断的实战系统
构建出属于你的诊断方向
那么我们如何诊断呢
第一个就是我们正要针对性的找问题
然后发现问题并解决这个问题
解决这个问题之后我们要去评估
我们解决这个问题后的效果怎么样
如果这个效果很好
那么我们继续把这个有效的方法持续的应用
如果这个效果变差了, 那么我们还要往回再走一轮, 再重新找问题去解决问题, 这样按照这个逻辑在这里持续的评估, 持续把有效的方法积累下来, 那么我们的整个店铺的整体的效果就会更好
那么具体怎么样去诊断一个店铺, 我们分为两个维度, 这边是第一个维度, 这边是第二个维度, 第一个维度是根据店铺的布局跟平台的趋势来进行诊断
第二个维度是根据我们自己店铺里面的店铺的综合数据的细节等维度去进行分析
那么我们来先看第一个维度就是店铺布局和平台趋势
这个就是关于流量的问题
比如说我们店铺所做的赛道
不同的赛道它的流量都是有天花板的
比如说你做RTS或者是做定制赛道或者是做半托这种产品
那么它的流量瓶颈都是有一定的局限性的
这个会涉及到的一个就是你的目标, 国家跟人群, 以及你要选择推广的产品跟推广的精神度, 都会决定着你这个店铺整体的一个流量的天花板, 第二个就是你产品流量的布局, 也就是你的店铺里面可能有普通寻盘品, 寻盘可交易品, RTS, 半拖款, 那么你的店铺里面如果都能覆盖这几种产品的话, 那么流量的天花板肯定是会更高一点的, 如果你店铺里面只有普通寻盘品,
那么你的流量肯定是会相对的少一点的, 所以为什么你的店铺流量一直增长不上来的时候, 除了这边店铺维度的数据外, 还有可能跟你的这个产品流量布局, 有着极大的关系的, 但是大多数人都是在困在这个板块里面做一些诊断, 没有跳出这个板块来到这个更高层级的店铺诊断, 那么就是这个, 因为这四大产品,
分品的流量, 决定着你的店铺流量的一个大小, 第三个就是你的店铺的新等级, 新等级越高, 那么他能够分配到的起始流量的权益, 或者是说你这个店铺能够获得高质量, 流量的分配权益会更高一点点, 所以这个新级我们一定要去重视起来, 我们前面也讲过了, 0 星到 1 星, 2 星到 3 星,
这两个维度都会有不同的流量分配的
所以我们一定要重视这个星级
因为它是决定高质量买家分配和排名加权大小的一个决定因素
第四个就是行业流量
也就是你们店铺流量增长的空间
比如说你的行业本身就是那么少的流量
你就不要去跟人家做很多品类的店铺去对比了
你店铺里面就做一两个品类
你去跟人家做十几二十个品类的店铺去对比数据
这种就没有什么参考价值了
而是你应该跟你同类的店铺去比才有价值
因为品类越多
那么流量可能会越大
覆盖的范围越广
所以这个你一定要去看一下自己行业
是不是你的品类很少
品类少肯定是流量很少的
如果你品类越多
那么整体的流量就会越多
去思考是不是要脱贫
能不能破片这些维度去提升
这个第一个板块就是从更大的维度去整段店铺
去拉升整个店铺的整体的一个流量
因为有些时候我们单独的从店铺细分维度里面去努力
是没有办法改变整个店铺的整体的一个流量增长的
所以有时候你如果在这个板块解决的很好
但是流量依然没有增长的时候
一定要跳出这个板块来看看店铺的布局是否合理
来看看当前平台的趋势是往哪个方向发展的
你不跟随平台发展那么你的流量将会越来越少
那么第二个板块我们来讲一下关于店铺综合数据这些细节的维度进行分析
我们只需要根据三个核心的主线去展开就可以了
第一条主线就是流量的问题
第二条主线就是转化的问题, 第三个主线就是订单的问题
你看店铺第一次肯定是先解决流量的问题是吧
有了流量是不是要考虑转化的问题
有了转化是不是要考虑订单的问题
也就是这个板块有曝光点击跟访客
那么有了曝光点击访客之后就会有寻盘跟贴母
寻盘跟贴母之后就会要解决订单量的问题
所以我们在解决整个店铺细分维度的时候
我们一定要先根据这三大问题
然后再找到对应的指标进行细分去优化
比如说你店铺现在就是在曝光点击访客这些板块存在的问题
那么你就不要先考虑后面这些问题
你应该先把前面这些问题解决了
有些店铺就像我们前面上一小节所讲的
连访客量都不多, 那你就直接来问, 为什么没有选拔, 那你要先解决访客的问题啊, 所以不要直接就跳过了这些流量的问题, 直接问到结果的问题, 曝光跟点击之间, 会有一个衡量的指标, 就是点击率, 那么点击率, 我们只要在0.8到4%都是比较合理的, 那么我们这里看的数据, 全部都是全店的综合数据啊, 不是单品, 也不是单个板块的数据,
而是整个店铺的综合数据也就是我们数据概览里面的总的数据
那么这些维度如果存在的问题
那么你在拆分比如说点击率出现问题
那么你是不是刚才上面这个是店铺综合数据
你是不是要去找到产品
哪些产品影响了这个店铺里面的综合数据
那么这个产品是否有推广
推广了是不是你要去找到对应的计划去进行优化
你看这些维度都是从大范围到小范围
再缩减到啥小范围, 这样去找问题, 就能够快速的找到问题了
关于这个直通车综合数据分析, 我们在直通车课程已经讲过了
那么你就根据那里面的方法去学习就可以了
第二个就是判断, 点击到访客量, 这个数据, 我们要通过访问点击笔去判断
为什么要判断这个数据呢? 因为这个数据大小就决定着我们店铺
当前自然流量的增长情况
这个数据越大
那么说明我们整个店铺的自然流量是在增长的
如果你越来越小就相当于
你很多都是靠那些搜索流量
或者是说靠直动车搜索点击来的那些访客
所以说就没有自然流量
没有自然流量的话
你的直动车成本就会越来越高
这是一个维度
那么如果你的曝光点击访客
这边这个板块没什么问题的时候
那么我们就要考虑, 访客量非常多, 为什么没有循环, 这时候我们就要去看我们的整体的循环转化率, 循环转化率就是循环出于访客, 那么我们一定要去参考行业的数据来进行对比, 大部分行业都是在6%到10%的转化率, 周秀的大多数都在12%以上, 但是呢, 并不代表这个是固定的数据啊, 因为有些行业它是比较低的, 那么那种情况,
你就要去参考整个行业的数据就可以了, 不一定要参考这里的数据, 询盘来了, 这些的问题也解决了, 但是它有订单, 为什么他们有订单呢, 那你就要看它的订单转化率怎么样, 跟别的行业差距有多大, 如果是差距很大的话, 那么我们没有订单时候是不是要反过来去解决询盘的质量问题, 以及询盘的精准度问题, 是不是就回到了我们之前所说的那些具体的方法,
去操作就行了,所以说我们如果你要去分析整个店铺的时候, 你就要从大的维度去看, 先看我们的综合数据, 流量是否存在问题, 转化是否存在问题, 订单是否存在问题, 如果这个不存在问题, 那么就直接跳到这个转化问题, 转化不存在问题, 那么就跳到这个订单问题, 如果订单这个板块出现问题的话, 肯定就是会跟上一个环节, 也就是说你的寻盘问题有关的,
如果你的试盘出现问题, 那么可能就比前面这个板块有相关性的, 所以我们是根据不同的维度去找到我们店铺当前处在哪个阶段的哪个问题, 然后再针对这些指标来进行去判断它是否落在合理的区间, 如果它落在合理的区间, 那么我们是不需要去做太大的调整的, 如果它比这些维度都低而低,
很多数据, 那么这个时候我们一定是需要去进行调整跟优化的, 你看我们从上面这里已经把这个店铺维度分析了之后, 店铺里面的整体的维度分析了之后, 店铺里面是不是有产品构成, 有产品一, 产品二, 产品三, 有大量的产品组成是不是, 店铺存在问题, 肯定反馈出来的, 产品里面肯定存在问题, 产品里面存在问题, 产品里面存在问题, 你看, 店铺存在问题, 你看, 店铺存在问题, 你看, 店铺存在问题,
那问题之后, 我们就要到产品去, 找问题, 那么产品找问题, 怎么找问题呢? 我们前面讲过, 产品优化, 产品分析, 这些板块都讲过了, 那么你就要去找对应的产品, 特别是优先考虑那种爆品, 实力优品, 它们的数据的变化, 这种产品数据的变化, 才是最直接影响整个店铺的效果了, 所以优先考虑爆品跟实力品, 那么
爆品跟实力品找到了是不是你在用直动车在推广呢, 如果你用直动车推广, 是不是能够针对这个计划里面去调整这些产品, 或者是调整你推广的一些指标, 来提升这些产品的效果, 是不是就能够倒推过来, 反作用于我们整个店铺, 所以我们找问题的时候都是从大的范围, 再缩减到小的范围, 然后解决具体的某个产品的问题, 或者是某个指标的问题,
那么你这个店铺才能够真正的解决问题, 这个就是关于我们整个店铺的一个诊断的一个整体的框架, 这里面有一个核心的一个流程, 加上判断的指标, 加上它具体的一个参考判断的数值, 再加上一个你要遵循这个流程去缩减, 去查找问题, 那么你最终才能够找到问题去解决就可以了, 那么这个店铺诊断框架我们就讲到这里, 希望这个诊断框架能够帮你
可以梳理你自己的一个知识体系, 能够帮助你在后期的诊断中快速地找到问题, 解决问题
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里, 下节课我们再见